I'm going to use some physics to answer
the question of whether or not Rapunzel
really could support someone's weight
just with her hair so I'm going to make
a few assumptions the first is that it's
possible to grow your hair to be 20
meters long and that's a conservative
estimate of what Rapunzel's length was
hair usually takes one year to grow
about 15 centimeters so to grow 20
meters of hair would usually take a
hundred and thirty three years that's if
everything else goes well the current
world record is about five and a half
meters and mine probably a measly 1.3
meters something like that but let's
assume it's possible now Rapunzel's hair
is going to weigh a lot I found one
estimate that twelve centimeters of hair
would weigh 0.62 milligrams that works
out to be a hundred and three milligrams
for twenty meters of hair multiply that
by a hundred and fifty thousand hairs on
an average blonde head and we end up
with fifteen and a half
kgs of hair now let's look at some
forces downwards we have the force of
gravity acting on the hair that's going
to be a hundred and fifty-five Newtons
add the weight of say a prince and take
his mass to be 80 kgs that gives us a
total downwards force of 955 Newtons now
there's actually no way that Rapunzel's
neck would be able to withstand that
kind of force and in fact one of the
weakest components in this is going to
the the bonds between her hair and her
scalp and connecting to the skull so the
hair would actually probably get ripped
out there if all of that force is going
straight to the roots however that
doesn't mean it's not possible to hold
that weight
Rapunzel just needs to hook her hair or
tie it around something to take that
force directly off her neck and head if
she can do that then lifting a prince
shouldn't actually be a problem because
in fact human hair is incredibly strong
each strand of it can hold about 100
grams that's about one Apple so put
together for a hundred and fifty
thousand strands human hair should be
able to lift 15,000 kgs that's
incredible and that's a casual 188
apprentices